Well,
hello, how are you? Sal and Jaramillo greet you
with the brief information for today, Monday
, May 17, with the new measures
announced by the CDC. Many gyms
now allow fully vaccinated people to enter
without their mask.
Personal trainers from a gym
in Henderson said that they already  they are seeing
a lot of people exercising without a
mask since the change however
most of these places are not
asking for proof of vaccination
consequent most hotels on
the strip are allowing
people in without wearing their mask
this new rule  includes all the
properties of the investor of costales in
properties of cers entertainment and
nearby in the round round while they
adapt to the new rules announced
by the cdc many properties also
advance in terms of the capacity
allowed within their establishments
many days they find themselves with
100 percent capacity in the
gaming area and more
slot machines to learn more you can
enter our page
youzhny dotcom diagonal in Spanish
however another is the outlook for the
court county school district as
it announced that both its workforce
and students must continue to
wear their masks while they are
in the facilities possibly  until the
end of the school year
and now we turn to the weather forecast
today we will have a maximum of 88 degrees
with chances of rain we will have
temperatures around 90 for tomorrow
and Wednesday and they will drop again for
the rest of the week nice day I am
I left jaramillo and  This was their brief
informative of them Neil in Spanish
[Music]